[Music]
hey how was your weekend are you just
asking me how my weekend was so then i
can ask you how your weekend was and
then you can tell me some wacky story
i mean kind of but doesn't everybody i
mean if you think about it it's like
wait i'm having deja vu
have we done this before i also feel
weird that
something is off
tarik amber are you okay tarek what the
hell
why do you have that on that meme is old
already let it go
what meme i saw president sanders word
at his inauguration i thought it was
cool what do you mean president sanders
joe biden is president what no he isn't
bernie sanders is oh this must be the
multiverse
that thing all the marvel avengers
movies are always talking about
when the lights flickered i guess our
dimensions got crossed
wow that's amazing what is it like with
bernie sanders as president
everyone's getting health care student
loans were canceled there's talk of
reparations
everybody started dressing like him like
they work in an old clock shop
it was super cute for a couple days then
white supremacists burned the country to
the ground because
they do not take change well
oh amber quick we're in the multiverse
who's the president elizabeth warren
really
i have to know what it's like it's good
everybody's getting health care
student loans were canceled there's talk
of reparations
earnest white women have become the new
stars of twitter etsy is the new apple
it's very cute
at least it was until all the white
supremacists burned it to the ground
they simply could not fathom a world
where their president had a period
amber who's the president cory booker
and everybody is still like
wait what really how who's your
president
ted cruz really he killed so many people
i can't believe trump's first executive
order was taking amber's show and giving
it to me
and i can't believe a second was cloning
all white men
who's the president you
perfect
[Music]
hahaha
you